[Music]
alright guys welcome back to another
episode of wfe this is the slim edition
Steve's enjoying his Noah bake Noah's
Bagels which I think will be great
anyway we're joined today by with a good
friend of mine Sam
Samuel bass I've known Sam we know each
other kind of since college yeah 20
years
yeah well college so we have a good
friend between us Brian but and I was
Brian's roommate for a while but Sam and
all of us went to school together UCSB
and so got your pride how do you not
know this anyway
yeah no I was up there but but so we had
a little like group of friends and Sam
and and Lorraine your lady yeah his wife
we're both there
so but anyway Sims since we're talking
about gaming Sims a lead designer you've
been working in games for a long time so
we thought we'd bring you on and you
know talk about your history our
grievances get your thoughts burn my
enemies burn your enemies but no so
let's talk about let's talk about you
Sam so after school after we met after
school you got you kind of just got into
video games right well it was kind of
weird so it was actually before school I
like I moved to I'm English originally I
moved to the u.s. in 95 Ryan and so you
were just a school like you'd just been
there a couple years out here yeah it's
like and I came I got into UCSB I knew
nothing about Santa Barbara but I'd seen
the soap opera and it looked cool so I
figured I'd go there and I was living up
in Marin County with my uncle I was
living in their garden in a Japanese
teahouse as you do and I was looking to
get into games I've been making my own
game since I was a little kid because I
had an Atari computer which meant that
it didn't have any games like no one
made games the Atari cuz nobody bought
Atari computers when you say Atari
computers so like it was like a
Commodore but at our
it was an Atari 400 oh wow which is 16 K
RAM I think right it was around the same
time it was like early eighties like my
dad bought one in like the late
seventies early eighties and so I was a
little kid like all my friends in
England like it was Commodore 64 and the
ZX Spectrum were like the and the
Amstrad ago to include the amp straddle
my friend Peter will yell at me on
Facebook with the computers and the
Atari was a pretty minor thing and so I
had to make my own games and so when I
was about 7 8 years old I started like
making my own games so you're like the
Doogie Howser of Atari games yeah
exactly if Dukey has made a really
crappy version of operation wolf so when
I you know when I got to the US I was in
Rin well you know LucasArts is a lot of
game development out there and I was
like I should get into games and my aunt
was taking a community college class and
that was an ad for like entry level game
developers making like 650 an hour at
this startup company called run an
entertainment right our IP and so I went
in they hired me I don't know why they
had me I had like who's your charming
British fellow exactly they thought I
was smart that's the thing with the
accent at macquaire know we're in
England are you from what town I'm from
a little town called Wallingford it's in
Oxfordshire which is sort of like like
about a mile an hour outside London it
could be Temecula you know what Football
Club are you know right yeah Football
Club Oxford United was our team they
were like a I think a third tier they
were really not good oh very nice I met
a bunch I've never heard of them I'm an
Arsenal FC guy yeah Arsenal yeah I was a
little supporter girl okay yeah they're
good at this point I don't really watch
Pramila yeah I wonder I watched the I
watched the I watch the World Cups yeah
we can lose to Denmark and like the
quarterfinals oh yes you know it's I'm
big and I'm big into the Premier League
and you're big into FIFA
I'm making a FIFA I got it I got into
FIFA then I got into the this stuff
we're talking about yeah isn't amazing i
play fifa yeah it's amazing a suck at
FIFA but I still play it it's great
they're always good right yeah it's like
it's like four hundred people in
Vancouver making beef every year Wow
four hundred huh yeah sort of getting
ahead of myself a little bit yeah yeah
so you know my uncle aside and I went in
they hired me I had like crazy hair I
was like all Punk at the time and you
were a little punk rock back when I met
you managed to escape with no tattoos
but otherwise yeah I was pretty Punk and
they hired me and I'm a I spent like
three years making a really bad game
called neo Hunta which is what happens
when Americans try and do like an anime
type game and I like the thought well
what kind of game was it it was like a
rail shooter' sort of like you know leaf
limb forces like was that kind of era of
gaming and but it had it was like 30
hours long it had dialogue by Orson
Scott Card for some reason which is
awesome yeah who is a very strange man
and there's game yeah he and I argued in
a Novato food court about whether Pulp
Fiction was good he didn't like poop
face oh dude it's a damn good movie
he was like Mormon or something he's
very very very real oh yeah he's talking
about that very damn good movie but yeah
he's a good writer book but it was kind
of weird meeting someone that you kind
of think you think of as a hero and
you're like but yeah so we did that it
got I think back when next generation
magazine is the thing we got 1 out of 5
stars next gen next gen full quote this
is an awful game and but it was kind of
my oh how did that make you feel when
you read that room I do it sucks I was
like but it was like this weird game
where they were trying to a hybrid of a
rail shooter' an adventure game it was
pretty bold and I learnt a ton I worked
with some really cool people yeah you're
all still in the industry Island kind of
how games are made right cuz I always
thought you know it's like you make your
own games and you're like oh yeah you
just show up and go I want to make this
and you actually show up and it's like a
whole structure and you know that's the
thing like it's a bureaucracy you don't
just it's not like one person does
anything well except for maybe today
with mobile
things like that you get people we get
like little Abdul like flappy bird and
that kind of stuff where it's like one
dude and he's like this is the thing I
made and you know if it goes well you
can make a bunch of money oh yeah you
know it's I so I ended up from the
getting I worked running for a while and
ended up getting a contract gig through
them at LucasArts late nineties doing
game called Force Commander and the
great experience of being at LucasArts
the day after the Phantom Menace came
out oh wow I did not like that movie I
despised that movie a shout out to my
brother I despise it my brother has
decided that he defends the prequels now
really because why talk about that horse
commander though cuz I remember a lot of
the games like I got I remember the
shooter games and stuff I'm Jedi Knight
yeah but what was Force Commander so
like what was the object that was a
real-time strategy game it was like
Monaco or like Starcraft or whatever
only it was built in this weird RPG
engine that Ronan had written for
another game huh and so it was like a it
was a project they've been restarted a
bunch of times and we came on board to
basically get it done what was it it
wasn't like rebels versus rebels but you
basically start out it's actually kind
of funny it reflects to the more
contemporary styles you say it was
classic Star Wars and you start out as
stormtroopers and on Hoth right yeah
it's got a I remember that got a sweet
HOF level yeah I remember that game and
you start out and you're the Empire and
at some point you defect and it was
interesting because you were a
stormtrooper and it was right when the
prequels coming out and they couldn't
tell us the stormtroopers were all
clones and all that kind of stuff so we
have this weird story where you're a
stormtrooper but you don't hang out
whether the stormtroopers you live in
this like separate bunker you and your
brother and we just like kind of
[ __ ] how you came up with the story
to my boss Gary Gary Gabbar who you know
teaches game design I think in Austin at
UT the padding somehow Mike's pickup
that's no yeah I'm a natural drummer I
have to watch out
but yeah Gary's awesome guy he wrote
story he's he made that game happen and
it was known as it was okay received
okay it
right but the fact that ship too tall
was amazing given what a mess it was
when we all kind of came on board but
yeah yeah I mean they're gonna be tough
to like come on to a project that's
already started and then you guys have
to try to clean up whatever is there I'm
the I'm the patron saint of doing
projects I hey what year did that the
Star Wars game we were talking about
when did that come out that was like
early 2000 okay okay
so yeah we were in development when the
Phantom Menace came out and yeah I went
to see the Phantom Menace um thing is
when we showed up at what next day you
know I was a contractor I didn't really
work that I was just there and I showed
up and I'm like how people gonna be
because there's two ways people could
react to that mm-hmm I I was convinced
the Phantom Menace was good for like
five minutes after I saw it and then my
wife was like no that movie sucked and
I'm like you're right I couldn't stand
the kid actor what's that kids oh I feel
bad for the client is that the one when
they're doing the race everybody does
that they go oh I felt like I feel bad
to the story like that plays Anakin yeah
direct actors yes I mean you're a child
actor it's not gonna go I'm tell you
that's the worst one out of all of them
did yeah I actually talked about this oh
my god it was so back of the clones is
my least favorite because it doesn't
have a point yeah I mean all the
prequels were just they were rough but
but I mean going back to it okay so but
this is but this is a good segue because
you did Force Commander and then right
after that you went to well I went to I
basically I took I went back to school
to graduate and I took a year off from
making games cuz I was so but you did
cuz he I didn't know you were doing that
stuff when we were in school I remember
there's a nice summer break but all of
us were doing like we were in animation
class like would you an animation with
us yeah I did with Driscoll right yeah
UCSB film studies right and yeah I went
there because there weren't a game
program so I love movies and I figured a
lot of that would be applicable and some
of it is like certainly storytelling and
all of that right key but yeah so I took
a time off I did some game journalism
I got to learn what it's like to be
hated on the Internet in 2000 yeah
different dot-com gathered rolls back
then
you give a square-enix game a bad review
and men they're all over there are some
angry dudes oh my god like send you
emails to your hotmail account really
I'm gonna kill you in big red text and
you've gotten death threats because of a
video game because yeah I think it was a
very loose and it wasn't even I gave
Chrono Cross a bad review yeah I was
like it was alright I just love Chrono
Trigger and Chrono Cross wasn't as good
as Chrono Trigger and I said that and
apparently I sinned against something
well I used to love reading like the
game magazines were always in the
beginning have like people reader
feedback and stuff and there was just so
many people that are so impatient and
angry about things yeah and of course
you're like why do you even care like
it's a game and like why you're writing
to a game magazine to be angry over
something that they said about something
else it's validating your purchases it's
very strange
it's a way it's a weird culture and the
thing is I love a lot of gaming culture
I grow oh yeah yeah I had a Nintendo I
remember the Nintendo though the
original one we NES yeah then you oh you
put the cartridges in you press it ya
know the Mike Tyson punch-out one and
you always sound like a guy from like
like like the BC era you always like I
had a box and you put a thing well you
know which one I'm the contractor is
Metroid Megaman you know the because I
remember Mike Tyson's punch-out right
wouldn't they changed they changed
because they lost a licensing for Mike
Tyson yeah became mr. dreamer yeah mr.
dream where they made yeah so let's go
this is a fun activity okay so that
console top 5 games let's go around this
way okay but I want to get back I want
to get go ahead go ahead
just on that console though just on that
con on NES yeah I mean do you have super
Mario's always like the top okay is that
one of your choices yeah just do three
well Super Mario yeah you have Metroid
and I think Zelda I mean those okay
those are three go ahead
yeah it's apartment Nintendo is
Nintendo's
Kanon mm-hmm so it's like yeah I thing
is growing up I wasn't allowed game
consoles I had to have computers because
they consoles went educational my dad's
really smart he's like you gotta you
gotta learn how to that's gonna change
the range of ones but I you know it's
weird I got really into the emulation
scene in the nineties and so I ended up
kind of experiencing all of those games
on a like a 486 25 if okay but yeah for
me like Metroid okay Metroid is amazing
so the old ones the Craig set are all
just like canon perfect game so it's
kind of I'm not going to include them
yeah this is a variety but yeah so
Metroid Double Dragon lon Nintendo is
which is totally different to the arcade
game and is a really badass game and in
general like that sort of tech knows
technology appreciated yeah I remember
that one man
I remember that one because at our local
round tables Pizza
they had look this is back when they had
that games you know or the mini arcade
in the pizza joint and they had a double
dragon there and I remember that one was
always you'd have to put your quarters
up and wait because there was the hot
commodities it was like I remember when
I might where I grew up because I grew
up in the country yeah arcades will like
you'd get like a traveling fair and set
up in the field outside my house and
they'd have a not cave yeah and I
remember all the like the old like scary
kids but only playing double dragon
dragon and yeah secret to double dragon
is reverse elbow like yes basically you
can win the entire game by hitting those
two buttons and facing away from rice
it's it's a weird trick but uh I
remember learning that and then just
annoying someone by beating the entire
game right right and then and so one
more Nintendo game that's tough there's
so many so many good ones so I'm gonna
shout out kind of an obscure one called
crystallis which is kind of like a song
and it's one that like my wife loved
when she was a kid and it's on the
Nintendo mini right yeah and it's it's a
pretty pretty sweet game it's like a lot
of depth for his time it looks really
cool it's actually kind of fun so my my
friend's five-year-old they got him in
an NES classic for Christmas
yeah and so we he and I were like
playing some games he's not quite at
that final fantasy RPG type level but
just playing you know Kobe you know
Mario Megaman just watching watching a
kid light workout and how these things
work and getting really mad at make a
man cuz it's so hard
those games are so I suck so hard at
Megaman I love those games but I haven't
beaten a single Megaman alright quick
over here three oh yeah I was I was gay
I was like my I was like trying to think
yeah cuz that was you said can I say my
wish I might I might not say the Contra
now since you've ruined my list already
alright well obviously Mike Tyson's
punch-out alright I'm gonna have this is
like this might sound like a generic
choice but Excitebike oh yeah because I
remember just hours of just Excitebike
yeah and all alone just playing that
game by myself and I'm not gonna say
contra although contra is on that list
since you already said it I want to say
something else I like that game because
I don't know what it was there was
another game in the arcade during I
don't know if it was before or after it
was called I don't know if you remember
this it was called rowdy champ
yeah and there's two sticks there's two
sticks and I remember that you did the
moves with like directional
directionally right it would do like a
sweep kick if you went all the way down
and if you went on the left one north
and then the right one to the 15 it
would do the jump kick like you would
have to memorize the these movements do
you guys remember crying I used to I
used to play that oh my god that was a
great game yeah yeah so those are my
choice thanks for ruining my contra - oh
come on as you know I wanted to get - I
want to get to I mean cuz I mean there's
so much old I want to get into the
arcade stuff too because I have a lot of
memories in the arcade right it's a big
arcade yeah because these kids nowadays
are so damn spoiled
then we had to actually get on our bikes
go to the roundtable go to the 7-eleven
stack article you know our pockets with
quarters and they don't know what it's
like man well we can get into a but yeah
150 cents and you die yeah and then I
remember when Dragon's Lair hit good
luck getting on that but let's get back
to all that I want to I want to finish
Sam's history and then we okay I'm sorry
I'm just kidding oh no no I like where
you're going yeah I don't want to talk
about me no no I just want to talk to I
just want to talk about like we'll
finish your history so we can kind of
talk about that and then then we can go
into whatever so I did games journalism
for a bit and then the internet
collapsed in like 2000 2001 yeah was
money in it yeah I remember you were
like I was at a dot-com that yeah I was
I was working for I think daily radar
and then just they couldn't really pay
me anymore and so I was like I should
get back into making games cuz there's
money in that and through a weird second
set of circumstances I interviewed to be
on the Sims team up in the Bay Area oh
that that didn't work out for weird
corporate reasons but they got me an
interview to be on the metal one a team
in LA and I already lived in LA so that
was great I mean I didn't have to move
and so this was right after the original
Medal of Honor team had all bailed right
and so that I had half of them the PC
team which was was this scene in Texas
this was a TA at that point was the AEA
was basically DreamWorks interactive
slash yeah right okay and so the middle
of on a PC team which was in Texas they
became Infinity Ward right on to make a
gazillion dollars and the middle one a
console team went on to be spark and
kind of suck sorry I'm sure there was
some good people I've made games to suck
too and so I got hired on my lavona made
a game called Medal of Honor Rising Sun
that wasn't that great in about nine
months of insane crunch wow that seems
short for a game it is I my what's the
normal schedules like what two three
years for example my theory is that like
a normal like shortish production
schedule is 18 months 18 it takes 18
months to see if your game is good right
and if you're doing a sequel maybe you
could like mess with that but minimum
you kind of need 18
unless you're making something very
simple right because it takes that long
to get it stood up and then you got to
work on it until it doesn't suck now at
this point what were you on the game you
were a I was a I guess a mid-level
designer I was alone I made I did built
one level Singapore sling it was the
stealth level so just first people
understand so by building a level you
were designing the layout
yeah so I was in a Toulouse 3d studio
max which is a 3d modeling program it's
not really good I'm interested in it I
know I am I'm just I'm trying I'm trying
to understand it because I don't know
that the technological you just like
playing and he does I just like playing
the games continue so what you do is
like you know you come up with an idea
for a level and they already had a story
so I pick one and then I kind of pitched
what to do with it which is Singapore
and well 2 is occupied so it's sort of
sneaky and a Singapore and you got to
like attend like this Nazi meeting and
steal a thing and so you you then I did
a 2d layout it's actually the Medal of
Honor process is pretty cool I did a 2d
layout just an illustrator
mm-hm I'm like hey this is what I think
it would play like and then and we'd
been at this point they were still
getting the game looking so I couldn't
there wasn't a lot of software and then
we did a thing which I think a lot of
developers should do if they don't which
is I basically we got all the important
people into a room and I had a giant
DUPLO set and I literally laid out each
second section of the game and showed
how it would play out Wow play goes here
and bunch of guys come out and then you
got a rescue a hostage here and find
their secret pickups here and so we did
that over about three days to my level
and during that period like the
producers and all the powerful people
are there and you kind of iterate the
idea make it more interesting
it's how one of the levels send up with
an elephant with the mounted machine gun
on the back which in retrospect was not
that smart but it seemed funny it seems
it was a game that world war 2 very
seriously well not take it very
seriously strange but yeah so I ended up
building this level right because I knew
you did level design and it'll be for a
while and yeah I was basically obsessed
with Deus Ex at that point still my
favorite game Deus Ex is I love that
game great I've beaten that like it is
now yeah at the time it was a toast
I own storm a lot right and I love that
game I've beaten that I played through
it like 10-15 times now every couple
years I read stole it did you ever play
Deus Ex no I never gotten kind of
cyberpunk it was pretty cool the cool
thing with those games is you could kind
of improv your way through the game like
it wasn't like a shooter or a stealth
game or whatever it's like you could
shoot people could sneak around you
could have conversations like a Bioware
game and try it they're always like
final Mass Effect oh so sometimes you
could literally just talk your way out
of a situation rather than getting into
a firefight was it like
choose-your-own-adventure like that
it was like that but an FPS it was
pretty awesome you know I'm trying to
clarify for the audience - I love the
deaths and the sort of the children of -
sexy games like Dishonored and dude I
love Dishonored okay generation Festa
yeah you love Bethesda I love Bethesda
big fallout guy I love for you I had a
200 hour save game oh my god I got to
the end I think it was the Point Lookout
yeah my dude on an island watching the
sunset stay there buddy I do stuff like
I shot everybody in Megaton and then
they all become it became my enemy so I
couldn't even like live there anymore
did you blow up the bomb yeah yeah
sometimes you gotta blow up the bomb I
love the games like that where there's
there's no set way and to do it you can
just come up with your own any game you
can load up and go screw around is the
most fun oh I love that stuff yeah
because you know I love call of duty
games and stuff and then there is a set
way to play if you're calling you now
and after a while I'm like I don't want
to do it that way what if I went that
way and you're like the invisible wall
you can't get that way that yeah but
it's cuz there's so much money in those
games that building like one of those
areas is super expensive so you kind of
have to funnel people through it do you
remember that a console Dreamcast there
was a game back I think early 2002 I
think it was called Shamu Shenmue anyway
they're making where where where you
could just walk around you
to pay it off yeah yeah they're making a
third I remember playing this thinking
how cool was because I could just walk
around but I had it there's a curfew
then you had to come back home and a
certain it was it was like one of the
first like open world open world yeah
like game I'm actually moved I just
bought a vintage mint Dreamcast off
friend of mine in Texas had a family yes
and he's like you want it and I'm like
sure
so I'm so I've never owned a Dreamcast I
removed playing Soulcalibur with you in
your Bryant's living room way back over
so converse so which one's Brian it can
you met my you met my friend Brian you
know Brian he was over it
Bob's for the fight for the UFC fight
well let's go back to ok but let's go
back to I started EA right did Medal of
Honor I did a game called Goldeneye
rogue agent that is just mmm that game
sucked and was that the sequel after
sold and I it was a sequel cuz original
was groundbreaking that one I used to
play that in 64 and cause so much dude
and so we did goldeneye rogue agent and
that was just like a misbegotten project
again really talented people and that's
the thing is you can work on a bad game
and have a really talented team you can
work with people who are crazy smart and
really good artists and all that and
still make a bad game I mean some of its
luck of the draw
and I think Goldeneye was ultimately
just a flawed idea did that didn't work
out so well and I transferred to the
command & Conquer team the doing real
time strategy because I done force
command I kind of knew how that works
and that was it you you were worked on a
bunch of different command and conquers
right I did so we so what we did is the
first game I was on was at Lord of the
Rings strategy game battle for
middle-earth to that's in the
Smithsonian why is fans really like it's
a great game a game yeah yeah and so
that was my first good really good game
of the a I was really proud of that and
it was a short development cycle well it
was just this was like 2006 six quick so
on that game weren't worried were you
still doing level design I'd kind of
moved up to a most seniors assign roles
so I did I did about half the campaign
my laid out levels I did the scripting
maybe not half maybe like a food cause I
mean that's that's and that's pretty
cool at that point to be and I love Lord
of the Rings and it was when those
movies were coming out oh yeah
it was like such a fanboy moment for me
and we would what was nice as we weren't
doing the plot of the movies we were
kind of doing deep flaw stories so we
got to get nerdy as hell on my leg
what about us gilja and you know what
about you know Glorfindel and glowin and
like these sort of obscure characters
from well not obscure if you read the
books but they're not really in the
movies they're often swapped out for
other characters I think Glorfindel
became Liv Tyler somehow in the film but
we did that and it was really well
received ei didn't expect it to be any
good they just you know they're like you
need to make something and they don't
really care so they left us Lo and we
made this pretty badass game and from
that ei was doing this game called
Tiberium that was kind of a FPS reboot
okay now I had gone to I had been a TA
at that time I don't know I maybe Chris
or somebody was working that I've never
seen that was like a first-person right
yeah it was gonna be a pretty awesome
game yeah it looked amazing it just
didn't like it was a first-person
command & Conquer game so I was like a
sci-fi shooter way before like destiny
halo 4 halo halo halo 2 yeah yeah like a
CNC hello but it was before like - you
know because the first trailer was
really good oh yeah I remember that gun
the needler remember oh yeah yeah it's
still decent right yeah holds up it
still looks pretty good yeah but so we
would that that was coming about and EA
was worried that there'd be a fan
backlash because command & Conquer is
traditionally a strategy game series
real they hadn't made one since
Tiberian Sun in 99 and so coming back in
like oh seven with a shooter yeah you
know we were just talking about it like
internet was gonna get mad and so it
basically became a thing and I may be
getting this wrong I wasn't at the upper
echelons at the company but it seemed
like they were like what have you guys
did come out of cauca
and we'll and I'm like one of my
favorite series of games ever I love
to this day it's I love those games and
we're like yes and so we did CNC three
again a relatively short cycle now she
and c3 was people really did they like
that game right yeah it was received
yeah sold really well
people were stoked about it I got a lot
of dumb jokes into the dialogue which
made me really happy so for that one I
did yeah bunch of missions I read a lot
of dialogue and so you wrote the
dialogue yeah for the eyebrow mission
dialogue it's because I studied
screenwriting in college so I could kind
of pitch in and help with the writing a
lot a lot of really dumb jokes in there
you play my mission then you were at
that point where you lead designer on
that one I was senior designer senior
and then from there we kind of our team
had gotten pretty successful so he's
putting multiple teams and the big part
of the team went on to do kimono conquer
Riddler at three which I helped had on
before it shipped that's a great super
weird game but it's great and I went and
became lead designer on the kimono
conquer three expansion Kane's wrath all
right and I got to just nerd out hard
because one of the things with CNC three
was he kind of wanted a clean break with
the previous games like a passage of
time from the old fiction to the new
fiction so we didn't have to spend ten
minutes going here's what happened right
and so Kane's wrath was kind of the idea
of let's bridge the gap between Tiberian
Sun and sea and c3 and it means I got to
sort of direct story like we did all
this live action video mm-hmm with
actors oh cool got to meet natasha
Henstridge she was really lovely person
I was in Tim Curry was Tim Curry was in
riddle at 3:00
Tim suit so riddle at 3:00 at Tim Curry
at JK Simmons at Jonathan price at Jenny
McCarthy you like price he's in the game
of Thrones
yeah he's the High Priestess high
Sparrow Sparrow Oh great actor yeah yeah
I like him and they were all like super
nice people and we're basically making
low-budget sci-fi right and these super
talented Shakespearean actors show up
and do a tall silly stories and that was
really fun and so ciency with Ken's
wrath I got to work directly with Jo
koukin who's the actor who plays Kane
right into myNet called who's got the
bolt dude with a goatee who's the bad
guy he was like man back
and he's super nice guy I think he made
Bank off ei so he probably doesn't work
anymore Burnie
yeah he's I love Joe and we had a really
good time just doing this like crazy
sci-fi story where I you know it got
really weird and you're playing as an AI
and it gets very surreal right it's like
a ghost zombie AI that appears where I
remember showing that video to my boss
and he's like that is what we call Sam
bass moment right there yeah it just
gets real weird on you yeah I guess a
year well you're a weird guy so so after
that game so I know you then you went to
work on so we did riddle at three and
then the T we did c'mon Akaka four which
was kind of a disaster and I can't talk
about in great detail because right it
caused problems but right that game I
came on in the middle I took over as
lead designer just to get it out the
door and didn't go very well I wrote the
story which wasn't great I take full
responsibility for the story on that
game kind of sucking and we got it out
the door and they laid off our whole
team so for me and a couple people right
now which is weird I survived many
layoffs at EA and why no survivor's
guilt from that I think it's tough
because I mean you know I had a friend
get I got two people I know that will
let go from EA aside from you and it's
it's tough because it's a big
bureaucracy right it's it's a cool
campus I mean I'll give them that but
where's the campus located and Playa
Playa del Rey Vista yeah it's it's in a
swamp on top of an Indian burial ground
it's not a joke this is the truth that
is that's freaky
yeah that's murdered a little bit yeah
it's a little bit cuz though it's
actually now dice Los Angeles though I
don't feel people and it's currently
crazy friends there apparently it's
really awesome it's on an Indian burial
ground that's what they told us yeah
it's a world war two bomb testing site
it was a bunch of things you shouldn't
build a building on what she's you know
going back to so I want to get back to
the facts so you know whether or not
you're working on something I mean it's
a lot of people right so it's I mean so
you know you go to movies and you go to
games today and there's so many people
working on things and there's so many
moving parts and so many facets and and
then there's time crunches there's
budgetary concerns so it seems like it's
tough you know because I mean how many
games are you thinking gonna come out
blow you away and then you're
just like you're disappointed you know
that's and it's tough well that's one of
those things is if you look like in the
1930 mm it's like ei woodchip like you
know 30 games yeah right now yeah
Activision they'll put out like four or
five or five big and did you know so
it's really a lot of sequels most of
your sequels like Battlefront 2 is EA's
big game there's Madden that's FIFA have
you played are you a fan of that he's
against it for some reason it's it's
good I play because I'm not a big multi
play guy campaigns nice I mean the thing
is the thing is it's not just I'm
against it it's a got a lot of backlash
because of the way II eight deals with
its what have you read any of the
criticism and why people are upset with
it well I don't really if I play if I
enjoy the game enjoy the game yeah I
don't I don't let that deter me from
that you know I'm not saying I'm not
saying that but I'm just saying like
there's reasons why that game right now
is very controversial and contested
because right now they're even talking
about putting bills in Congress that are
about microtransactions because they
feel like people are like well there are
not there are none on there well they
disabled them yeah that why did they do
that because we try to buy the gems or
something in color that basically they
it's like dude we're trying to give you
their money no it was monetized like and
you know I can't speak to the
development teams experience but you
know is monetized like a free-to-play
game but it cost 60 bucks and that I
think pissed off a bunch of people and
part of the problem with being a TA and
this is the thing I learned there is as
much people who hate you just close your
EA and anything you do they can stay
angry right so it's like you know that
and they just I think the monetization
design was not really done with the
player in mind right supposed to let's
get as much money as possible let's get
to this let's get to this I think it's
tough when you have games right you're
paying 60 bucks which for a lot of
people today is a lot of money you know
and and now you're paying 60 bucks and
you're like oh I want to do something
else in the game but I need to put
another 20 down I need to put another 40
down going back to curse of Osiris
because we're that's how we started
necessarily true I mean it I feel this
the my opinion is if you are to spend
more money than you know
right for the microtransactions or
whatever you're paying for that if you
want to get better gear than you're
paying for that you but right but now
it's an unbalanced game because yeah but
they're pressed for it they pay two
extra $20 right you paid extra money
they deserve to have a like if their gun
has a different capability there's a kid
out there that can't afford a better gun
well that's that's the way the thing is
that the way life is set up is that's
not life is set up that way well then
maybe you should be no no it's more I'm
just saying it's more Act
it's what I'm saying is that's it this
is more accurate to real life it's like
you're not complaining about some guy
who has a yacht it's like yeah this guy
has the money to buy the yacht so I
think part of it comes from there is
like traditionally multiplayer gaming
there's an expectation of parity and for
me it doesn't bother me when it's like
co-op play or even single-player like
I'm playing shadow of war right now in
ps4 just monetized the ass yeah I know I
haven't explained to the viewers what
like well what do you mean by monetize
well basically there's a lot of stuff
you can pay for mm-hmm like what that
let you like skip basically skip the
story mode well basically you can get
more powerful rather than just playing
through and leveling up you can buy a
bunch of levels but here's the thing now
that we're talking but yeah that's the
dilemma now we're talking but this was
the backlash the backlash was that let's
say you want to get Princess Leia right
and you want unlock her but you need to
spend like three years to unlock not
necessarily you know no exam I'll
explain to you how it works on
Battlefront depending on each round
there's a certain there's certain heroes
that you could unlock um upgraded
stormtrooper might be a 2000 if you want
to be Boba Fett it might be four
thousand five nine and then when you get
to like the the higher level people like
you know Princess Leia or Han Solo it
might be eight thousand but you could
obtain it by playing the game it's
thirty years yeah but here's what you're
missing they fixed it after they
released it so when it started out
people did the math and they go it's
gonna take me seven thousand hours to
get Princess Leia
right and so that became a big sticking
point
okay I understand that all's fair fair
enough so now what you're seeing is the
fixed version right you're playing now
is it's been thin I actually credit to
ei for seeing the backlash and doing
some and not sticking their guns but
actually going because that's the thing
is if I prove if I want a place that was
gay mine I spy I didn't I did I didn't
know that I if I want to be you know
like I buy a stylist game I don't want
to just be grito or some other dude be
Darth Vader
Bossk yeah nothing against boss you know
it's like I I want to be da Veda and it
takes me like 40 hours to be Darth Vader
I can't stand I understand I can
understand why people are mad so they
changed it because of the complaints on
that that was unfair to for that and I'm
saying now
okay they fixed it they should bring
back the microtransactions they should
bring it back so if a person wants to
pay more money they could upgrade and
advance their player that's all I'm
saying this is this is this is argument
maybe even against capitalism in some
ways but the argument in general is
people when they feel because going back
to games when we were a kid if you got a
game cart for 60 or 65 bucks that was
everything you didn't need to pay for
DLC you didn't need to get the new
outfit you didn't need to get another
gun you had a whole game ready to go and
you weren't missing anything and I think
people are even cool today with DLC
right yeah like people like overwatch
yeah okay okay I see your point but my
point is okay just hear me out
you don't have to agree yeah if it takes
one kid like a trillion hours to to
grind to obtain the next thing but then
a person with money just says [ __ ] that
I don't want to do that here's 20 bucks
then I mean I think that that's just the
way life is
I'm not you could grind you could grind
you pay for everyone paid for the
initial game but I'm saying if you have
money you should be able to spend it and
then not be able they're paying for you
know it's like I think the argument
always become you don't want to grind so
they're paying for it well I think the
argument becomes what's happening with a
lot of games is where people are like
hey I'm cool if you want to get a cooler
outfit and a cooler ship and a cooler
and it doesn't affect gameplay then I'm
cool with you buying no no no but that's
what but that's what they're paying for
if they're paying
to make their character a little bit
more powerful they paid one hard-earned
dollars to do that so I think the main
difference is battlefront 2 so like look
about front 2 and then look at overwatch
overwatch oh I'm a fan of both and
they're both great game I love them both
but you what you're only paying for
cosmetics you're paying for different
skins different outfits I get that
whereas battlefront - you couldn't
basically get stuff that means you're
more likely to win a match and that you
know there's arguments for against that
but there's this you know that's
argument right there this is what we're
arguing about the Internet's just to let
just to clarify I'm more on the side of
the kid with no money because I can't
spend the try no but someone had my
brother he was called his complaints cuz
my brother has a lot of money you know
he's got more money than I do obviously
but he's saying dude like I'm trying to
give it they put they took it down I'm
just trying to give them my monuments
yeah it's one of those problems so this
actually sort of I went through this and
chunk of my career so uh yeah after I
survived the layoffs we were doing a
game the rig's originally a full price
$60 come on a Conca game and then at
some point it became a free-to-play game
and the problem is like real-time
strategy competitive real-time strategy
multiplayer demands parity because it's
not like it like it really like the
community the people who play those
games if you can buy your way to winning
in a RTS match which is tough those
games are how those games are really
hard like it's like the hardcore like
Korean dudes you can click 500 times a
second I get it yeah yeah like if you
could buy a way to compete with one of
those guys it would kill your community
and so we were trying to find a way to
make a free-to-play now why is that
explain why that why would kill the
community I don't know a little bit
going back to what you talked about with
destiny with going invisible and
everybody using that stuff you don't
want to play against those guys because
you're like they're just you know that's
not a good example because cuz everyone
has the capability to do that in destiny
you're not paying for that okay everyone
has the capability as a knight to dr.
example oh but that's not a good you
know so let me let me
within the context of a strategy okay is
so in a shooter
you'll one character and yeah you
couldn't gain some extra abilities and
you can gain sort of a leg up in a
real-time strategy game what you're
really doing is a complex series of
strategies where you're taking out your
buildings you're building different
units and trying to get to a certain
strategy while also playing in a very
high level micromanaging all YouView
units and so if you throw in a thing
into that balance because achieving
balance in RTS like this is something I
don't balance RTS games my friend Greg
black who is phenomenal game designers
who I shared an office with him and he
balanced amount of conquer games like
giant spreadsheets and going really
working out okay so if they build three
of these tanks and two of these does
that give them an obvious advantage over
any other strategy because you don't
want it to be one way to win the game so
the moment you throw something else in
they're like oh but if you spend 50
bucks then your tanks shoot fire and no
one else can do that it throws the
entire the a medal and sort of the micro
and the macro of the game out of whack
and then people don't want to play
multiplayer because it's unfair it's
unfair and so that now we're talking and
it's like it makes the the playing
ground the playing field unfair and I
think in strategy like shooters you can
kind of skate by but you know generally
shooters think of cosmetic I call it
beauty egos cosmetic right like you
can't buy your way up the you know no
not that that's a great point but can
they can they alter it to where they
don't have a huge advantage but maybe
slight advantages where they the twenty
dollars it's worth or twenty dollars but
it's not completely like shifting the
playing field where it's like they might
have like this other scope but they do
that a lot of games and a lot of
shooters they do that it's you can kind
of get away with it not yes it would
just throw it's like I don't here to
argue with you yeah I mean I'm just I
want to explore both I want to explore
both are using which that that's all
yeah a good example would be like League
of Legends or dota you know that kind of
game which like hardcore they basically
replaced realtime strategy into
competitive play and I we suck at League
I am so bad at that game but I watch a
lot of it and those games a single like
if a unit had one statistic that was one
point higher if you paid money for that
it would throw and this is games with
league play with real competitive league
play big prizes you could do that it
throws the entire balance of the game
out of whack they've been making League
for like what five six years now they're
still bouncing it they still continually
recent good community there's some good
Korean teams oh there's an Asian - yeah
they're talking about them winning
something in eSports this year yeah and
yeah it's like huge where you could win
like you know that's not and so the
moment you throws like they the micro of
that game if you in the moment you throw
something into that you throw it out of
whack you basically destroy your scene
all right so you're say okay I see your
guys's I mean my thing is I just want to
explore both sides but here's the other
thing with microtransactions that's
another element of this and this goes
back to what was the one Oblivion right
elder scrolls oblivion
there was like sama the horse armor
right the horse armor you could buy it
what was it like seven bucks or so yeah
like 20 by and then your horse could
have armor and it was what's funny is
Bethesda generally does great DLC but I
remember everyone was so mad about what
was a horse armor right and now like it
was like I play I play Street Fighter 5
like you can buy a new skin for you
that's you know like five bucks
gives him a hot dude be it or whatever
but the horse armor was such a big deal
that people were so upset that like you
were gonna spend like what was it like I
don't remember the price but you're
gonna spend a lot of money for just
armor for your horse it was like a new
texture but that was a big deal this
goes back to microtransactions okay is
there a way where you could create
microtransactions in these different
types again they do ever purse okay so
let's let's use ever verse for an
example like ever verse and destiny -
what is it you could spend money but
that time said they should at least you
get cosmetics from you get ornaments
battlefront they can't they just bring
back on micro transaction system words
they can it won't help you in the game
but it can make you look cool
the main problem is that they it's that
system is so into woven into battlefront
to its design and like I can't speak for
the developers that but yeah feels like
it the leveling system is so key to the
game's design sort of extra cating part
of it is gonna be a huge amount of work
I mean that was a massive game made by
massive teams our friends who worked on
it on battlefront and yeah and it's it's
beautiful and it's look like I have a
really good time playing it yeah Anna
you can see all of that money on the
screen like they obviously put a ton
into it I'm a Star Wars fan and his very
style was I love the night I don't well
and I love the campaign it was like a
really solid campaign like I'm like can
you give me a new Jedi Knight now no no
I because we're kind of limited on time
so I just want to talk about if you want
to talk about I know you might not be
able to mention specifics but you're
working on stuff now yeah I can't really
talk about what I'm working out Rhys I
have a giant scary NDA that I saw but
but I moved into via like I finally got
laid off from EA around 2013 I survived
twelve years they gave me a nice payout
they did I was ready to leave so I think
it was good timing ultimately I was the
one guy he wasn't really sad that day
and well there are people crying when
they go crying it's like you know people
are pretty passionate about what they do
and they believed and we did works in
this thing for like nearly four years
then I got shut down for a shift and how
close was it to being fair
well it wasn't ready but it was wasn't
like 80% 70% no we were gonna go into
sort of like a public alpha and so I was
and we'd started that and it just ie I
guess he I didn't think we'd ever make
any money which is you know it's their
money so and so I moved on I did I just
free-to-play games in China to you know
pay my mortgage and then I started going
to via and I started a company with some
friends called three one zero our IP and
we did a game we did a game called
a drift that was which was like huge
like people were that was like one of
the big first VR games that everybody
who dived about there was do it we're a
launch title for oculus rift we sold
really well right and for the oculus for
the oculus were unwise we're not in
PlayStation VR
for reasons I can't address but we're on
PlayStation 4 just not in VR and it's
like a you know not I think I hate the
term walking simulator it's kind of
derogatory but it's like a I like think
about a first-person experience
exploratory game where you're in the
ruins of the space station you were the
commander of you wake up in the wreckage
and you have to work out how to get home
that's and so you can die but they're
not aliens or space Nazis or whatever I
had its running joke that this based
Nazis would appear in the end cutscenes
and so we did this game that was kind of
an experimental exploratory VR game
small team like six of us like busting
ass for two years I work from home which
is awesome yeah that's yeah and we did
that came out and it did very well but
unfortunately VR was a small market so
we just you know well it's a future
though the VR forefront and and it
didn't have the user base yet you know
but they actually did did well they got
disabled people people who game reviewed
well people liked it I still get like
feedback from people on how you know how
much fun they had I'm really proud of it
I mean can we check that out how do we
check that out I mean it's on some pcs
it's it's not on Xbox because we never
got that version done
I think the oculus PC is what I'd
recommend and it's like a two three-hour
game and it's probably on sale right now
but yeah so we we kept going from a
couple years after that and eventually
company had to shut down which was sad
and so I moved on to this other company
we VR in Venice who are cool people
hired me to do a thing that I can't talk
about with some people I can't talk
about but I'm doing a cool thing and it
feels interesting because there's a
desire to put some traditional games in
VR that I don't think is necessarily a
right fit like destiny and VR I'd rather
just play destiny yeah TV but if you can
give me a game where I'm in the world of
death yeah like exploratory more like I
could hang out and destiny and laser
world and I think there's and you can do
more traditional games you can do
shooting mechanics you can do all of
that but one of the big challenges in VR
is moving like that first-person
movement yeah if you do that and you
were gonna be a headset and you're using
a joypad to move around you can make
yourself puke really
and so you know like I love like doom
2016 the doom they came out here before
last I love that game right but you move
it like 90 miles now and there's a VI
version where you teleport because
moving at 90 miles an hour it's just
sick you buff and so what we're doing
now the product I'm working on is very
experiential and it's about beings
willed and it's boring hanging out and
doing fun stuff
yeah and it's more about creating a
space where it matches kind of your room
and you can just hang out walk around
and you again it's not a huge market but
it feels like when I think that's that's
the future right there was in Star Trek
in the holodeck um yeah manda making
that stuff and I feel like we're at the
cusp of something that's so cool in a
couple years I think VR will be you know
much more you just go to rot walk on the
beach or something yeah yeah like the
Weaver the company I work for they're
famous for a project I didn't work on it
I came on board after it shipped called
the blue alright which is it's amazing
and it's they should they have a full
product and the idea is it puts you in
underwater in different places like you
can be underwater on a wreck ship and
there's a whale that comes around
hanging out or your deep-sea like by the
Mariana Trench sounds like a glowing
jellyfish migration and it's just this
it's not a game it's an experience it's
like you know five today's hangout in a
space but I will never be underwater
with a whale and so what do you what are
your thoughts on games like stardew
valley like I love that stuff I like
games where people are trying to find
other ways to play cuz I love little
gaming yeah combat and all of that but
sometimes yeah you just want to be a
farmer or like I love the Sims the Sims
is amazing so maybe you could combine
the two maybe like eat like do what you
just described but then kind of mix
that's keys other anything where it's
gonna go oh yeah created see that where
you can farm and yeah exactly like you
grow mom or you grow fruit trees or
something oh you know you like the
harvest
what ops one of my favorite things Wii
Sports Resort on the Wii
what's so funny man I'm being serious I
just have this idea of you the VR helmet
just like going into the I would love to
do that
because like in Skyrim I'd like the that
aspect
have you played Skyrim in via no ok I
gotta look into that yeah and I mean it
can make you sick but I think because
that world is so good yeah it's so good
yeah like you could just walk into this
we're real close to time so I just want
to do one quick round about what games
are we looking forward to I'll tell you
right now cuz next month there's a next
couple months there's some stuff so I
kind of start out yeah because you start
I'm looking forward to the the Red Dead
Redemption to - damn right so cuz I am I
was a big fan of the first one um that's
about it that's only one cool I'm
looking forward to the shadow Colossus
remake I hope it's good oh well I didn't
know there because that's my favorite
games next took coming out it's coming
out and he just took my favorite that's
my that's blue point yeah exes they're
really good so I'm excited for that and
then I'll just say quickly got a war and
Far Cry 5 or like tied for me it was all
five loops yeah in Montana
I remember part my three militant yeah
guys that's gonna make a lot of the
internet man but yeah it's like I have a
lot of friends working and got a war so
excited for that game but Dragon Ball
fight Izzy all right now like Mexican I
love one-on-one fighting games and I'm
not a huge Dragon Ball guy but I love
Arc System Works the people who made
that game and it looks amazing and
completely crazy so I am down to play
that you have Red Dead Redemption - I'm
very excited I'm out go to war I'm very
excited about and then it's weird I'm I
have such a huge backlog because I've
been working a lot Anna shut up evil
within to which came out like all right
five six months ago I finished that this
morning that's the horror game yeah no
that's scary but it's fun game yeah but
yeah so it's kind of I was like looking
out across the year and I'm like yeah
Dragon Ball and then this Red Dead
Redemption
I don't know what comes in between
between is it is there it gonna be
another GTA coming on red Dead's their
next big game yeah they were like every
four years the Rockstar yeah
I don't read down the gtas I love those
yeah alright guys well yeah great man
thanks for coming brother
oh yeah that was awesome that was
awesome yeah so guys thank you for
joining us for another Effie I hope it
was informational and interesting it was
really a pronoun and yeah see you next
time thank ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]